[Music]
on this friday night an emotional plea
for help we really do believe that
they're out there
they're all survivors a canadian woman's
desperation to restart the search for
her boyfriend
among dozens missing at sea global news
has learned the upcoming throne speech
will focus on a long-term
pandemic plan plus the severed head of
canada's first prime minister
how did this get the stamp of approval
and the cheap shot as nfl players try to
sideline racism
in a new era for the league
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight with a desperate plea
for help from a canadian woman
who believes her boyfriend and others
are still alive
despite being lost at sea over a week
ago the gulf
livestock one carrying about 6 000
cattle sank off the east china sea on
september 2nd
three of the crew were rescued one of
whom later died
charlie gray was due to meet her
boyfriend william main prize in the
coming weeks
after being separated during the covet
19 pandemic
i'm really looking forward to finally
being together and
yeah and journeying together from that
point on
so um yeah it's been really frustrating
having
you know covid and then obviously this
is just devastating to say the least
this week japan's coast guard scaled
back its search but as redmond shannon
reports
friends and family of the crew say the
rescue efforts must continue
this is the gulf livestock one heading
into typhoon masack
last week pretty wild
among the 43 crew members on board
adventurous australian
william main prize sending regular voice
messages to his toronto girlfriend
charlie gray i realized today it's about
a month
until i'll be seeing you which i'm
psyched about
but main prize clearly realized this
storm wasn't routine
really safe it's a little bit crazy busy
it's like
super gnarly weather on this thing the
gulf livestock one had been taking
thousands of cattle from new zealand to
a port in northern china
on september 2nd near southern japan it
took on water
and capsized the japanese coast guard
initially found
this man in the water i am only one
yes they would find two more men
one of whom later died forty crew
including main prize
are still missing aussie stockmen like
him are
renowned for being tough we really do
believe that they're out there
they're all survivors and the technology
and the life rafts and boats that are
missing are also meant to survive these
sort of things
but following another typhoon the
japanese coast guard scaled back its
search
this week devastating loved ones of the
filipino new zealand
and australian crew so the fact that it
stopped or at least slowed to a more
normal pace just
felt like it was way too soon you know
and he really is one of those people
that's just
he's just every good way that you could
describe a person and
um he's just yeah generous and
compassionate
funny um so caring so good with people
the australian government is assuring
families
japanese air and sea patrols continue to
search for survivors
redmond shannon global news london
to the pandemic now and the surge in
cases of covet 19
in canada with numbers on the rise
ontario premier doug ford is urging
residents
to avoid large gatherings that province
recorded its highest daily total of new
cases
since june all i've been asking is
please try to avoid these big gatherings
uh please try to avoid you know the
the weddings that i heard were 150 170
people
just follow the guidelines and everyone
everyone will
will be okay today ontario reported 213
new infections passing the 200 mark for
the first time
in three months quebec recorded 219 new
cases
in the west bc recorded 132 new cases
while alberta has 111 new cases of
covid19
canada's first voluntary quarantine
facility opens tomorrow in toronto with
funding from the federal government
it'll cost 13.9 million dollars to
operate the 140 room center
over the next year it's aimed at those
who can't self-isolate at home
users of the hotel-based facility will
stay in their rooms for 14 days
and get meals and regular check-ins
toronto public health will determine who
is eligible but the location isn't being
made public because of privacy concerns
ottawa plans to fund similar sites in
other municipalities
global news has learned how the
government plans to deal with the
pandemic
long term that's going to be the
centerpiece in the upcoming throne
speech
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson has been digging into what's
in that speech
and what isn't mercedes robin the speech
from the throne is what sets the
government's agenda and it will
primarily focus on
managing what's happening right now with
the ongoing pandemic
the government very much still sees this
as being in crisis mode
according to senior government sources
and there is a belief that covid19
could last in this current state for up
to another two years
the speech on the throne won't include
actual numbers or detailed plans
but rather it will chart a course that
the sources say will focus on stopping
another
backslide into the kind of numbers we
saw of covid19
early in the spring it will also set out
new flexible supports for canadians that
will focus
on health and finances expect to see
child care health care and housing as
big ticket items that the government
will be leaning towards
according to one senior source cabinet
is also weighing a significant injection
of spending for the provinces
to go towards things like long-term care
homes as well as programs that will be
targeted for those who were the hardest
hit in the pandemic
low-income women and racialized
canadians also expect to see
ei become more flexible lower on the
agenda that proposed green shift a lot
of people were talking about
multiple sources had told global news
that there were factions in cabinet
that wanted as much as 100 billion
dollars in green spending
but that's being put on the back burner
as the government deals with the
immediate threat
of the novel coronavirus mercedes are we
expecting anything in the throne speech
about balancing the budget and getting
out of all this spending
well robin the recovery is in mind as
you've heard the prime minister
promising to build back better
but not details on how this will all be
paid down
right now government sources say that
they plan to grow their way
out of debt by getting more people into
the workforce they're also willing to
abandon those traditional fiscal
measurements like debt to gdp ratio
in the short term the speech from the
throne will look at what one source
called a green recovery making canada
more resilient
to future economic shocks like pandemics
and doing things like bringing critical
supply chains
back here to canada but we won't know
details on the numbers or how they'll
get out of this for some time
the speech from the throne will be light
on those details we'll hear
something this fall in terms of a fiscal
update but don't expect a budget
until around march robin mercedes
stephenson
in ottawa the prime minister is weighing
in on the we charity controversy for the
first time since the organization
revealed it's shuttering its canadian
operations
justin trudeau has been criticized for
being too close to we but today he was
very careful
to keep his distance abigail beeman is
following the story for us abigail what
did the prime minister have to say today
robin the prime minister was asked
whether he took any responsibility for
wee's closure his answer was
long one minute and 42 seconds but in
that time he never mentioned the
organization's name
here's some of what he said we moved
rapidly
with a partner that we felt was able to
actually deliver it
obviously the way it ended up working
out
was really unfortunate for everyone
involved
especially for students said the prime
minister since the program that could
have been worth close to a billion
dollars never got off the ground
the deal fell apart amid a political
firestorm after it emerged
members of justin trudeau's family were
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars in
speaking fees for wee
events while committees trying to
investigate what happened are on hold
with parliament prerogued
the opposition is still pushing the
issue the ndp sent a new letter to the
lobbying commissioner
asking questions including whether the
kielberger brothers themselves should
have registered as lobbyists
even though 18 other members of the
organization did
during the controversy mark and craig
kielburger did not
the lobbying commissioner has opened a
preliminary assessment in this case but
does not comment whether investigations
are underway
the prime minister didn't offer any
specific comment friday about
news we is shutting down operations in
canada as i said i
regret not having recused myself in the
beginning because of the
perception involved there was no
conflict of interest here
so a doubling down on previous messaging
ultimately the ethics commissioner will
rule as to the question of conflict with
an investigation
still underway although trudeau
disagreed with the commissioner's
findings
the last time mario dion found the prime
minister broke the rules over the
snc labylin affair robin all right
thanks abigail
there's a new development tonight in the
raj graywall scandal
the former liberal mp has been charged
with breach of trust and fraud
the rcmp alleged graywall broke the law
by failing to report millions of dollars
in personal loans and that he used his
political position
to get those loans graywall has admitted
he had a gambling addiction and racked
up millions of dollars
in debt he claims the money came from
friends and family and that he paid it
all back
in 2018 graywall left the liberal caucus
he did not run for re-election
in 2019. oregon washington and
california are struggling to contain
dozens of wildfires at least 24 people
have been killed
several others are still missing the
unprecedented fires are being fueled by
hot dry temperatures
and as jennifer johnson explains the
weather isn't letting up anytime soon
from washington state to the u.s mexico
border the western part of america is a
blaze
hundreds of out of control wildfires are
scorching california
oregon and washington over 500 thousand
people in oregon have been ordered to
evacuate their homes
10 percent of the population an
unprecedented number
we have never seen this amount of
uncontained fire
across our state drone footage shows the
eerie devastation in some oregon
communities
residents had little time to get out
when the almeda fire came raging in
everything was gone i only managed to
grab my family and my dog and
it's awful in california six of the
state's largest wildfires have occurred
this fire season
daring helicopter rescues have saved
many but other residents have had to
take desperate actions
eight of us had to go down to the end of
our road
go into the sand and get down in the
water to avoid the fire
twice this week some california
firefighters had to deploy emergency
shelters like these
after being surrounded by flames we're
in the midst of a climate
crisis we are experiencing weather
conditions the likes of which we've
never experienced
in our lifetime climate change activists
say global warming
hotter than ever temperatures high winds
and little rain are fueling these fires
and many warn it'll only get worse
people
tweet the photographs of what san
francisco looked like yesterday and say
oh 2020 could you get any worse as if
once we're in 2021
these kinds of disasters are going to
stop happening san francisco which had
been a glow in orange
is seeing slightly better air quality as
winds died down a bit
it's been really difficult but further
up north winds are increasing
accelerating flames and more destruction
jennifer johnson
global news ceremonies are being held
across the u.s today to mark the 19th
anniversary of the deadliest terror
attack
in america's history
bells rang out in pennsylvania as the
names of the passengers and crew of
flight 93 were read aloud
the united airlines plane crashed into a
field after being hijacked by terrorists
on september 11
2001 everyone on board was killed
lee adler
a scale down ceremony was held at the
memorial plaza in new york
it paid tribute to the nearly 3 000
people who lost their lives when two
planes crashed into the towers
of the world trade center tonight double
beams of light will be turned on to
evoke those twin towers
it has taken nearly 13 years but justice
has finally been served in the deadliest
gang shooting
in bc history former red scorpions
leader jamie bacon
has been sentenced to 18 years in prison
for his part in what became known as the
surrey six killings
in 2007 six people were killed in an
apartment building just east of
vancouver
two of the victims were innocent
bystanders with credit for time
served bacon has five years and seven
months left
behind bars stamp of disapproval
coming up why did canada post print
these stamps
featuring the severed head of canada's
first prime minister
canada post is apologizing for printing
a stamp that features the severed head
of a john a mcdonald statue
that was pulled down by protesters in
montreal the stamp was printed through a
program
intended to help people celebrate
birthdays or anniversaries
but a federal employee used the program
as a means of protest
and solidarity with those who pulled
down the statute
our chief political correspondent david
aiken also happens to collect stamps
and it's not the first time canada post
has been pranked david
well that's right robin you know most of
us use stamps actually designed by
canada post like this
legitimate sir john a mcdonald stamp
this is from 2015
marked the bicentennial of his birth 1.5
million copies were printed up
but if you had a favorite photo and you
wanted to put that on a sheet of 50
stamps
it could would only cost you about 120
bucks but people have used that
vanity program for political and social
protest
back in 2006 frank magazine did that
printed up a few stamps one with a
disney character another was someone
wearing a nazi uniform and
back in the late 70s opponents of pierre
elliott trudeau
distributed what are called overprint
stamps you can see the words
fuddle duddle and r-i-p-p-e-t that were
over printed on actual canada post
stamps now
none of these are very valuable to
collectors you might find copies on ebay
for a few bucks these days but
canada post takes this very seriously
and they are now
reviewing their processes to make sure
that no stamp with an inappropriate
image ends up in your mailbox robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
still ahead the audition for answers to
solve live theater's pandemic problems
well they are topics we don't normally
hear the pope wing in on
in a new book of interviews the pontiff
refers to food and sex
as gifts from god that are simply divine
pope francis says the pleasure of eating
is there to keep you healthy and
sexual pleasure is there to make love
more beautiful and guarantee the
perpetuation of the species
he adds overzealous views on so-called
carnal sins that deny pleasure
have caused enormous harm covet 19 has
forced many companies to change the way
they do business
but there are some industries that are
in a prolonged intermission
live theater needs a packed house to be
profitable but as mike drolla explains
the seats are empty
this is the heart of canada's vibrant
theater scene
for six months its old heartbeat has
been missing
[Music]
live theater like sporting events and
concerts is all about
the audience if officials have begun
planning for a reopening
theater insiders aren't privy to them
the only people that can answer that
question
are the public health officials that
unknown
is causing unease in the uk theater
legend sir andrew lloyd webber says the
industry
is on the precipice it is it's in my
view
that i think we are now at the point of
no return really lloyd webber has asked
for a target date to reopen but that
hope is
partly built on the dream they'll be
able to fill every seat
and not the 30 percent capacity ray
finds one man's show in london
is limited to i mean these these large
shows
can cost up to a million dollars a week
to put on
so you can't bring in that kind of
income
at only 30 percent of capacity as it is
most
shows are budgeted to break even at 80
percent capacity
so what can be done can theater embrace
the digital world
and does that even work with live
performances everything right now is on
hold
including the burgeoning career of actor
hannah smart who wrapped up
touring as a cast member of we will rock
you in february
so i for six months lived out of a tour
bus and
toured everywhere from new york to l.a
texas
we did toronto calgary like it was it
was a dream come true it was crazy
the calgary native had high hopes for
the rest of the year
now she's looking for a retail job until
she can start auditioning again
in january february is kind of the the
main audition season
in toronto especially and so it's going
to be interesting to see what it looks
like
come 2021 to see if they can even do
auditions in person
so many what-ifs need to be resolved
before the curtain can rise again
microlight global news
up toronto the pandemic play the nfl
struggles to tackle
social injustice
you're watching global national
the nfl kicked off its season last night
but the backdrop to the game
was much more than football for years
the league has wrestled with racial
injustice and the freedom its players
have to express
themselves now confronting both
america's racial divide and covet 19
the nfl is back in the spotlight eric
sorensen reports
they stood together opponents
demonstrating common cause against
racial injustice
led by the new face of the nfl super
bowl mvp
patrick mahomes we wanted to show that
we're unified as a league
and we're not going to let playing
football distract us from what we're
doing and making change in this world
but the return of north america's
richest sports enterprise
showed the nfl still appears to be the
most conflicted league in pro sports
when the national anthem played the
kansas city chiefs stood but one player
took a knee
the houston texans only came out after
the anthem and when both teams gathered
for that moment of silence in midfield
there were some booze from the crowd
the players say their message of
equality was for a bigger audience
we wanted to use this big platform where
we know millions of people were going to
be watching
as for the crowd kansas city is among
the few teams allowing fans to attend
about a quarter of capacity spacing for
tailgate parties
distancing in the stands and the masks
all signs
one more sport is taking on covet 19.
it's a unique year
and we're all aware of it we trust the
protocol
but taking on racial injustice remains a
particular challenge in pro football
most players are black yet league
executives and owners are overwhelmingly
white
get that son of a off the field right
now
prodded by president donald trump the
nfl for a long time shunned the movement
started by quarterback colin kaepernick
who first took a knee to call attention
to police brutality toward black people
if i was george floyd but in the wake of
the death of george floyd
pro athletes led by the nba took a stand
postponing games to protest
racial inequality and as nfl players
unified to take up the cause
that anything is possible the league
with videos like this
seem to recognize the need to get in
step with its players and changing
society
sports has been a big part of social
change through the years
well i think the league acknowledged
that it failed they had to come out
and essentially issue a mia culpa and
try to be better this time around
for many americans it's exciting just to
have football again to distract from the
pandemic
but finding a unified voice on racial
equality
is a game still in progress eric
sorensen global news
toronto and that is global national for
this friday i'm robin gill the toronto
raptors have put racial injustice front
and center
and tonight ahead of their must win game
seven against boston
the city's mayor is cheering the team on
we are
so proud of who you are and what you are
and how you play
bring on game seven we're with you all
the way go raptors
that's the same suit he wore when the
raptors won last year now with a
matching mask
let's hope history repeats thank you for
watching have a great night and i'll see
you back here this weekend
you